Uno de mis primeros recuerdos
es que traté de despertar a un familiar y no pude hacerlo.
Y era solo un niño, y no entendí porqué,
luego crecí,
y noté en mi familia adicción a las drogas,
incluyendo adicción a la cocaína.
Últimamente he pensado mucho en esto, en parte, porque se cumplen 100 años
de la prohibición del uso de drogas en EE. UU. y Gran Bretaña,
y luego se impuso en todo el mundo.
Hace ya un siglo que tomamos la fatídica decisión,
de tomar a los adictos castigarlos y hacerlos sufrir,
porque creíamos que los disuadiría y les daría un incentivo para detenerse.
Hace unos años, observaba a algunos adictos en mi vida, a quienes amo,
y trataba de averiguar, si había alguna forma de ayudarlos.
Y me di cuenta que había muchas preguntas increíblemente básicas
que no sabía como responder,
por ejemplo, ¿qué es lo que provoca una adicción?
¿Por qué seguimos con esta perspectiva que aparentemente no funciona,
acaso no habrá una mejor manera que podamos intentar?
Leí mucho sobre el tema,
y no podía hallar las respuestas que buscaba,
y pensé, bien, me reuniré con personas de todo el mundo
que viven y estudian esto,
les hablaré y veré si puedo aprender de ellos.
No sabía que esto me tomaría 30 000 millas,
pero fui y conocí a todo tipo de personas,
desde el transgénero vendedor de crack en Brownsville, Brooklyn,
hasta el científico que invierte mucho tiempo
alimentando mangostas con alucinógenos para ver si les gustan...
y sí les gustan, pero solo en circunstancias específicas...
visité el único país que ha despenalizado todas las drogas,
desde la cannabis hasta el crack, Portugal.
Lo que aprendí y que cambió mi forma de pensar es,
que casi todo lo que creemos saber sobre la adicción esta mal,
y si empezamos a asimilar la nueva evidencia sobre la adicción,
creo que tendríamos que cambiar más, que nuestras políticas de drogas.
Empecemos con lo que creemos que sabemos, lo que pensaba que sabía.
Veamos con esta fila de en medio.
Imaginen que Uds., por 20 días, usaron heroína tres veces al día.
Algunos se muestran más entusiastas que otros sobre esto.
(Risas)
No se preocupen, solo es un experimento teórico.
Imaginen que lo hicieron ¿está bien?
¿Qué pasaría?
Tenemos una historia de lo que pasaría que se ha contado por un siglo.
Pensamos, que como hay ganchos químicos en la heroína,
si la tomas por un tiempo,
tu cuerpo se hará dependiente a estos ganchos,
empezarás a necesitarlos físicamente,
y cuando acaben esos 20 días, serás un adicto a la heroína. ¿Cierto?
Eso era lo que pensaba.
Lo primero que me alertó de que algo no estaba bien con esta historia
fue cuando me la explicaron.
Si al salir de esta charla de TED, un auto me atropella y me fractura la cadera,
me llevarían a un hospital y me administrarían mucha diamorfina.
La diamorfina es heroína.
Es incluso mucho mejor heroína que la se consigue en la calle,
porque la que vende el traficante está contaminada,
y contiene muy poca heroína,
y la que te receta el doctor es médicamente pura.
Y te la van a recetar por un largo período de tiempo.
Hay mucha gente en la audiencia,
que no se ha dado cuenta, que ha consumido mucha heroína.
Y esto sucede en cualquier parte del mundo.
Y si lo que creemos de la adicción es correcto...
todas las personas expuestas a los ganchos químicos...
¿Qué debería pasar? Deberían volverse adictos.
Esto se ha estudiado cuidadosamente.
Y no sucede; se van a dar cuenta si su abuela tiene una operación de cadera
no saldrá como una drogadicta. (Risas)
Y cuando supe de esto, me pareció muy extraño,
muy diferente a todo lo que me dijeron, todo lo que pensé que sabía,
pensé que no podía ser cierto, hasta que conocí a Bruce Alexander.
Un profesor de psicología de Vancouver
que realizó un experimento increíble
que creo que nos ayuda a entender este tema.
El profesor Alexander me explicó,
la idea de adicción que todos tenemos,
proviene, en parte, de una serie de experimentos
realizados a principios del siglo XX.
Eran experimentos muy simples.
Pueden hacerlos en su casa esta noche si se sienten algo sádicos.
Buscan una rata y la ponen en una jaula, y le dan dos botellas de agua.
Una es solo agua, y la otra es agua mezclada con heroína o cocaína.
Si lo hacen, la rata casi siempre preferirá el agua con droga
y casi siempre terminará con su vida rápidamente.
Eso es, ¿cierto? Así es como pensamos que funciona.
En los 70, cuando el profesor Alexander vio el experimento
se dio cuenta de algo.
Dijo: ¡ah! la rata está en una jaula vacía.
No tiene nada que hacer excepto usar drogas.
Intentemos algo diferente.
Y el profesor Alexander construyó una jaula a la que llamó "Parque de ratas",
que es básicamente un cielo para las ratas.
Donde tenían mucho queso, pelotas de colores,
y túneles.
Y lo que es crucial, tenían muchos amigos. Podían tener mucho sexo.
Y también tenían las dos botellas de agua, de agua normal y de agua con droga.
Y esto es lo fascinante:
en el parque de ratas a las ratas no les gustaba el agua con droga.
Casi nunca la tomaban.
Ninguna la usó compulsivamente.
Ninguna tuvo sobredosis.
Casi 100% de ellas sufrieron sobredosis al estar aisladas
y ninguna presentó sobredosis en un ambiente feliz y con relaciones.
Y cuando vio esto la primera vez, el profesor Alexander pensó:
tal vez es algo que solo pasa en ratas, son diferentes a nosotros.
Tal vez no tan diferentes como quisieramos, ya saben.
Por fortuna, hubo un experimento en humanos
dentro del mismo principio en la misma época.
Se llamó Guerra de Vietnam.
En Vietnam, el 20% de las tropas estadounidenses usaban heroína,
y si ven las noticias de esa época,
estaban muy preocupados, porque pensaban, ¡Dios!,
tendremos cientos de miles de drogadictos en las calles de EE. UU.
cuando la guerra termine.
Tenía sentido.
Se hizo seguimiento en casa a los soldados que usaron heroína.
El Archivo de Psiquiatría General hizo un estudio muy detallado,
¿y qué paso con ellos?
Sucedió que ellos no fueron a rehabilitación. No sufrieron abstinencia.
95% de ellos solo la dejaron.
Si creen en la historia de los anzuelos químicos,
esto no tiene ningún sentido, y el profesor Alexander empezo a pensar
que había una historia diferente de la adicción.
Dijo: ¿Y si la adicción no tiene que ver con los ganchos químicos?
¿Y si la adicción tiene que ver con tu jaula?
¿Y si la adicción tiene que ver con tu adaptación al ambiente?
Veámoslo así,
otro profesor llamado Peter Cohen de Holanda
dijo: "Tal vez ni deberíamos llamarlo adicción.
Tal vez deberíamos llamarlo conexión".
El ser humano tiene una necesidad natural e innata de conectarse,
y cuando somos felices y saludables, nos vinculamos y conectamos con otros,
pero si no pueden hacerlo,
porque están traumatizados o aislados o muy golpeados por la vida,
van a vincularse con algo que les de alguna sensación de alivio.
Podría ser juegos de azar, pornografía,
cocaína o cannabis,
van a vincularse o conectarse con algo porque es nuestra naturaleza.
Es lo que queremos como seres humanos.
Al principio, se me dificultaba, no me entraba en la cabeza,
pero hay una forma que me ayudó a entender.
Puedo ver, que sobre mi asiento tengo una botella de agua, ¿cierto?
Veo que muchos de Uds. tienen botellas de agua.
Olviden las drogas y la guerra contra ellas.
Es legal, esas botellas de agua podrían ser botellas de vodka, ¿cierto?
Todos podríamos estar embriagándonos, (Risas)
pero no lo hacemos.
Y como pueden pagar muchas libras
que es lo que cuesta entrar a las charlas TED, creo que pueden solventar
el beber vodka, por los próximos 6 meses.
No acabarán como indigentes.
No van a hacerlo, y la razón para no hacerlo
no es porque alguien los detenga.
Es porque ya tienen vínculos y conexiones
y quieren estar presentes para ellos.
Tienen un trabajo que aman. Y a personas que aman.
Tienen relaciones saludables.
Y parte fundamental de la adicción,
que pienso, y creo que la evidencia sugiere,
es el no poder soportar estar presente en tu vida.
Esto tiene implicaciones muy significativas.
Las implicaciones mas obvias son para la guerra contra las drogas.
En Arizona, fui con un grupo de mujeres
quienes fueron obligadas a vestir camisetas que decían: "Fui drogadicta",
y a salir encadenadas y a cavar tumbas mientras el público se burlaba de ellas,
y cuando salgan de prisión, tendrán antecedentes penales
y significa que nunca más trabajarán legalmente.
Este es un ejemplo extremo, evidentemente en el caso de las cadenas,
pero casi en todo el mundo
de cierta forma tratamos a los adictos así.
Los castigamos, avergonzamos, les creamos antecedentes penales.
Ponemos barreras para que puedan reconectarse.
Había un doctor en Canadá, el Dr. Gabor Maté, un gran hombre,
quien me dijo, si quieres diseñar un sistema que empeore la adicción,
deberías diseñar este.
Hay un lugar donde decidieron hacer lo contrario,
y fui a ver como funcionaba.
En el 2000, Portugal tenía uno de los peores problemas de drogas en Europa.
El 1% de la población era adicta a la heroína, que es increíble,
y todos los años, usaban el método estadounidense más y más.
Castigaban a las personas, las marcaban y avergonzaban,
y cada año el problema era peor.
Un día, el primer ministro y el líder de la oposición se reunieron
y básicamente dijeron, no podemos seguir
con un país donde más personas se vuelven adictas a la heroína.
Formemos un panel de científicos y doctores
para averiguar realmente como resolver el problema.
Formaron el panel liderado por un gran hombre llamado Dr. João Goulão,
para revisar la nueva evidencia,
y después de reunirse dijeron:
"Despenalicen todas las drogas desde la cannabis al crack, pero"...
y este es un paso crucial...
"tomen todo el dinero que gastamos en aislar a los adictos,
y en desconectarlos,
e inviertanlo en reconectarlos con la sociedad".
Y no es lo que pensamos sobre el tratamiento de drogadicción
en EE. UU. y Gran Bretaña.
Ellos usaron las clínicas de rehabilitación,
terapia psicológica, que tiene cierto valor.
Y lo más importante que hicieron fue totalmente opuesto a lo que hacemos:
un programa masivo de creación de empleo para adictos
y microcréditos para adictos para crear pequeñas empresas.
Supongamos que eran mecánicos.
Cuando se hayan recuperado, irán a un taller y dirán:
si le dan empleo por un año, pagaremos la mitad de su salario.
La meta era asegurarse que cada adicto en Portugal
tuviera algo que los hiciera dejar la cama en la mañana.
Y cuando conocí a los adictos en Portugal,
dijeron que al redescubrir su propósito,
redescrubrieron sus vínculos y relaciones con la sociedad.
Este año se cumplirán 15 años desde que empezó este experimento,
y los resultados están ahí:
el uso de drogas inyectables se redujo
de acuerdo al British Journal of Criminology,
en un 50%.
La sobredosis bajó y el VIH bajó tremendamente entre los adictos,
En cada estudio la adicción está significativamente a la baja.
Una manera de saber que ha funcionado es que casi nadie en Portugal
quiere volver al viejo sistema.
Hay implicaciones políticas.
Creo que hay una capa de implicaciones
debajo de toda esta investigación.
Vivimos en una cultura donde la gente se siente cada vez más vulnerable
a todo tipo de adicciones desde a un teléfono inteligente,
hasta comprar o comer.
Antes de empezar esta charla, ustedes sabían...
que no se nos permitía encender nuestros teléfonos,
y les diré, muchos se vieron tan mal como cuando
le dicen a los adictos que su vendedor no estará disponible
por un par de horas. (Risas)
Muchos nos sentimos así, y puede sonar muy extraño,
les diré que la desconexión es el motor más importante de la adicción
y está aumentando,
porque creen estar en una sociedad más conectada que nunca.
Pero me convenzo cada vez más que las conexiones que tenemos,
o creemos tener, son como una parodia de las conexiones humanas.
Si tienen una crisis en su vida, se darán cuenta de algo.
No serán sus seguidores de Twitter quienes los acompañarán.
No serán sus amigos de Facebook quienes los ayudarán.
Serán sus amigos de carne y hueso con quienes tienen relaciones
profundas, estructuradas y cara a cara.
Y hay un estudio que conocí gracias a Bill McKibben, el escritor ambientalista,
que creo que nos dice mucho sobre esto.
Buscaba el número de amigos cercanos que el estadounidense promedio cree
que puede llamar durante una crisis.
Este número se ha reducido progresivamente desde 1950.
La superficie que una persona tiene en su casa
se ha incrementando progresivamente,
y creo que es como una metáfora
de la elección que tomamos como cultura.
Intercambiamos amigos por espacio y vínculos por cosas,
y el resultado es que somos una de las sociedades más solitarias
que han existido.
Bruce Alexander, quien hizo el Parque de Ratas, dice:
hablamos de la adicción siempre como una recuperación individual,
y está bien hablar así,
pero necesitamos hablar más de una recuperación social.
Algo está mal con nosotros, como individuos y también como grupo.
Y creamos una sociedad donde, para muchos,
la vida se parece más a una jaula aislada
y menos a un "Parque de Ratas".
Para ser honesto, no es la razón por la que me involucré.
No quería descubrir lo relacionado a la política o a la sociedad.
Quería saber como ayudar a la gente que amo.
Y cuando regresé de este largo viaje y había aprendido todo esto,
miré a los adictos en mi vida,
y para ser franco, es difícil amar a un adicto,
y hay muchas personas en este auditorio que lo saben.
Estás enfadado la mayor parte del tiempo,
y creo que una de las razones por las que este debate es tan controversial
es porque llega al corazón de todos, ¿cierto?
Todos tienen un poco de ellos cuando al ver un adicto piensan:
quisiera que alguien pudiera pararlo.
Los guiones de como lidiar con los adictos de nuestra vida
son representados, creo,
por el reality show "Intervención", tal vez lo han visto.
Todo en nuestra vida es definido por reality shows,
pero eso es otra charla de TED.
Si vieron el programa "Intervención"
tiene un argumento sencillo.
Buscan un adicto y a toda la gente de su vida y los reúnen a todos,
los enfrentan con la situación, y les dicen, si no te compones
vamos a abandonarte.
Lo que hacen es tomar las conexiones del adicto,
los amenazan, y los condicionan
a tener el comportamiento que ellos desean.
Y comencé a pensar y a ver porque este enfoque no funciona,
y pensé que es como llevar la lógica de la guerra contra las drogas
a nuestras vidas.
Estuve pensando, ¿cómo sería ser portugués?
Y he intentado hacerlo ahora, no puedo decir que lo hago siempre
y no puedo decir que es fácil,
pero le digo a los adictos en mi vida
que quiero profundizar mis conexiones con ellos,
les digo que los amo estén usando drogas o no.
Los amo, no importa su condición,
y si me necesitan, vendré y estaré con ustedes
porque los amo y no quiero que estén solos
o que se sientan solos.
Y creo que el mensaje principal,
"no estás solo, te amamos"
debe ser en cada nivel de respuesta a los adictos,
social, política e individualmente.
Por 100 años, hemos cantado canciones de guerra sobre los adictos.
Creo que deberíamos estar cantando canciones de amor para ellos,
porque lo opuesto a la adicción no es la sobriedad.
Lo opuesto a la adicción es la conexión.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)